hey back home
al James
welcome video did you see the clip did
you see that people are blushing when
they really they're reading from your
butt blushing just watching it and I
didn't have understand it so yes it was
very funny but when you when you travel
around with this book do you do you have
to do you have to read from it yourself
no it's quite common the authors were
really really only ever done it once and
it was that was a very interesting
occasion and I haven't had to do it
again I just I just take question and
answers usually what I like to do so in
other words this is not your your
vocabulary in a way it's not this no
this is a fantasy that you know that I
wrote and I didn't expect everyone else
to it to be able else's fantasy that's
why do you have a picture of who your
readers are do you know who you're
either um my reign is a mainly women and
but they range from you know college
students right up to 80 and 90 year old
women it's across the board and and now
I'm getting men reading it as well which
is really about it's really funny what
do they want what do they want do your
readers there just want a good tale they
want a ripping yarn you know which is
it's basically a love story and that's
why that's why I think that's what with
some kinky sex in it which I think you
know if you take this panel yes
guess who would be a reader guess who
would be a reader him
yeah I see you okay on my way from from
New York and I saw a best-seller and the
Fifty Shades of Grey and I thought it
was one of those sad stories that I
normally would go for you know where
that first yeah I actually read the book
I started to read the book on the plane
and then suddenly I found myself looking
around this is and then I thought a lot
about why I read it to the end because I
hate to break the news but you will of
course not get the Nobel Prize for
Literature for the book but why do we
read it to the end because I think it's
I think it's the way you write about the
experience of sex from in a strange way
because it is here he swishes but still
from a woman specific would you say it's
a feminist book is that what you say
no it's think it's a very empowering
book for women that's what it says
that's the that's the feedback that I'm
getting and if you've only read the
first one then you'll know that you need
to read the whole trilogy and this this
young woman you know discovers herself
herself sexuality her own sexuality how
she can live with this particular man
and and she becomes incredibly strong
she's incredibly strong for the from the
from me from the beginning but that's
not obvious and he seems to be the
strong one but he isn't and that's the
that's the whole twisting and in the
story yes yes actually it's it's about
he's not unlike you he's rich he's by
any tool you want it's very powerful he
could be like yes definitely as you
envisioned oh absolutely
is it it could also be you describe him
as a as a dream man this this is great
he is to Sharada yes yes
would he be your dream man as well yeah
definitely so is your husband the model
or no in a word my husband though he's a
dream man on paper that's it he's a
fantasy he's a fantasy man and he's
fantastic on paper to live with him
would be a real nightmare I think I live
with the right one you have two sons
teenage I have two teenage boys yes are
they proud they're amazingly proud
they're amazingly proud and amazingly
supportive have they read know that
teenage boys show me a teenage boy that
reads up to his PlayStation or YouTube
or you know one of these other things
that that 21st century children have so
what what is what is your plan now for
the future how are you in like 10 years
in 10 years